aujourd'hui en zone blanche demain
connectés à la fibre optique 158
communes rurales des yvelines vont
bénéficier du très haut débit d'ici à
2022 un réseau déployé par le groupe tdf
une entreprise choisie par le conseil
départemental l'opérateur industriel va
investir 120 millions d'euros sur fonds
propres dans la construction des
infrastructures dans un premier temps
donc on repère qu'on appelle et les
noeuds de raccordement optique
ensuite on met des armoires de rue on
connecte tout ça en fibre optique
on passe par nos propres fibres optiques
con qu'on tire dans l'est dans les
fourreaux dans avec les permissions donc
de voirie il n'y aura pas d'argent
public
donc pas de l'argent d'impôts c'est un
investisseur privé que nous avons trouvé
tdf qui va porter cet investissement aux
zones blanches
une fois déployé tdf commercialisera son
réseau auprès des fournisseurs d'accès à
internet
près de 110 mille prise optique vont
être installés dans les maisons mais pas
seulement
il ya également parmi les habitants
énormément d'auto entrepreneur 1dans qui
sont disséminés dans la vire ce qui fait
que pour eux ce sera un très très gros
avantage que la fibre passe à leur porte
ça va permettre à la population d'avoir
un confort dans ce cas la connexion
internet beaucoup plus appréciable et
surtout ça va permettre au développement
économique de pouvoir vraiment s'ancrer
dans des territoires qui sont un petit
peu plus éloignés des zones très urbaine
la fin du déploiement du réseau dans les
communes du perray-en-yvelines et de
cheuvreux est prévue au premier semestre
2010 9 en cas de retard tdf sera dans
l'obligation de payer des pénalités